[Música]
Hola hoy en Science click el campo
electromagnético
imaginemos a dos personas en el vacío
espacial que intercambian una pelota al
enviar la pelota la primera persona se
impartirá a sí misma una cierta
velocidad de reacción del mismo modo Al
momento de recibirla la otra persona
absorberá al impacto del movimiento de
la pelota al intercambiar la pelota
ambos individuos han acelerado
inicialmente estaban inmóviles ahora
están en movimiento alejándose el uno
del otro a cierta velocidad si continúan
intercambiando la pelota sus respectivas
velocidades aumentarán en cada ocasión y
se alejarán cada vez más rápido es como
si fueran repelidos por una fuerza la
acción de la pelota puede interpretarse
como una fuerza de repulsión
en la escala cuántica este mismo
fenómeno funciona entre ciertas
partículas como los electrones que
intercambian constantemente fotones
virtuales
un fotón virtual es una partícula
resultante de las leyes de la física
cuántica que puede aparecer de la nada a
condición de que desaparezca lo
suficientemente rápido y sea imposible
de detectar un fotón virtual tiene una
energía determinada y su tiempo de vida
es tanto más corto cuanto mayor sea su
energía cuanto menor sea la energía de
un fotón virtual mayor será la distancia
que pueda recorrer pues mayor Será su
tiempo de vida
al intercambiar fotones virtuales los
electrones Sienten una repulsión una
fuerza que los aleja algo parecido a las
dos personas que intercambian la pelota
esta fuerza es tanto más fuerte Cuanto
más cerca esté en los electrones entre
sí ya que los fotones virtuales tienen
menos distancia que recorrer y por tanto
pueden ser más energéticos
muchas otras partículas intercambian
fotones virtuales Y a esta tendencia de
algunas partículas interactuar se le
llama su carga eléctrica
el electrón tiene una carga eléctrica de
menos e y representa simplemente la
unidad de base de la carga eléctrica una
partícula tendrá como carga eléctrica un
múltiplo de este ladrillo elemental
algunos objetos interactúan más que un
electrón podemos imaginar un objeto que
contenga dos electrones y cuya carga
eléctrica sería Entonces menos 2e además
algunas partículas como el protón
interactúan con los fotones virtuales de
forma inversa su carga eléctrica es
entonces positiva La carga del protón es
más 1e al igual que los electrones dos
partículas con cargas positivas se
repelen pero una partícula negativa y
una partícula positiva se atraerán
mutuamente las cargas del mismo signo se
repelen mientras que las cargas opuestas
se atraen
para tener en cuenta todas estas
interacciones introducimos la noción de
campo eléctrico
imaginemos una especie de tejido en
presente en todo el espacio si ponemos
un electrón con carga negativa el campo
se teñirá de azul a su alrededor por el
contrario si ponemos un protón con carga
positiva el campo Se volverá rojo de
forma natural las partículas escaparán
de las zonas que tengan el mismo color
que ellas una particular neutra sin
carga eléctrica no sentirá nada se
moverá en línea recta como si nada pero
una carga eléctrica positiva como un
protón será repelida por la zona rojas y
atraída por las zonas Azules
a la inversa una carga negativa es
atraída por las zonas rojas y repelida
por las zonas Azules
ilustremos el campo eléctrico con varios
ejemplos Aquí está el campo creado por
dos electrones
podemos ver por ejemplo que la posición
Central es una posición de equilibrio si
se pusieron a particular allí quedaría
en móvil un poco con una canica entre
dos crestas
he aquí el campo creado por un electrón
y un protón podemos ver que las dos
partículas se atraen el campo eléctrico
forma una especie de puente entre una y
otra
finalmente colocando una cadena de
electrones en un lado y una cadena de
protones en el otro podemos crear un
campo eléctrico uniforme una partícula
en este campo sentiría la misma fuerza
donde quiera que esté de esta manera
podemos por ejemplo poner en movimiento
electrones dentro de un cable eléctrico
una corriente eléctrica
es Entonces cuando entra en juego un
curioso experimento
imaginemos un cable eléctrico formado
por una larguísima cadena de protones y
electrones por el que circula una
corriente eléctrica que es simplemente
un movimiento de electrones a lo largo
del cable
imaginemos que situamos un objeto a
cierta distancia del cable Como por
ejemplo una manzana que tiene una
determinada carga eléctrica positiva
según las interacciones que hemos visto
antes cada protón del cable empuja la
manzana
pero al mismo tiempo Cada electrón atrae
a la manzana con la misma intensidad al
sumar todas estas fuerzas se compensan
perfectamente y la manzana no siente
finalmente ninguna fuerza de hecho
cuando la observamos permanece inmóvil
ahora le daremos una velocidad de
desplazamiento hacia la derecha
curiosamente La manzana es
progresivamente repelida por el cable
aunque no siente ninguna fuerza
eléctrica es como si otra fuerza
desconocida actuará sutilmente sobre la
manzana esta nueva fuerza es un poco
particular no actúa cuando la manzana
Está quieta sino Solo cuando se mueve
además esta fuerza depende de la
dirección y la velocidad a la que se
mueve la manzana
está sorprendente fuerza se denomina
fuerza magnética
para comprender el origen de esta fuerza
es necesario estudiar lo que nos enseña
la reactividad especial
para empezar observaremos la situación
no Desde un punto de vista externo sino
tal y como la percibe nuestra manzana
nos situaremos en su punto de vista en
el punto de vista de la manzana no es la
manzana la que se mueve hacia la derecha
sino el cable el que se mueve hacia la
izquierda
según la relatividad especial Cuanto más
rápido se mueva un objeto más se
contraerá su longitud en la dirección
del movimiento en nuestro experimento
los protones del cable se mueven ahora
con respecto a la manzana de este modo
se contraerán en la longitud del cable
como si los protones se hubieran
acercado ligeramente entre sí
en cambio los electrones parecen moverse
ahora más lentamente porque todo el
cable se mueve ahora hacia la izquierda
así que están ligeramente alargados En
comparación con el punto de vista
anterior como si los electrones se
hubieran alejado unos de otros
cuando se suman las fuerzas que actúan
sobre la manzana desde su punto de vista
ya no se equilibran hay más cargas
eléctricas positivas que cargas
negativas como resultado el cable
ejercerá una fuerza de repulsión sobre
la manzana que la alejará
progresivamente
teniendo en cuenta la relatividad
especial podemos ver que el campo
eléctrico generado por una carga se
deforma cuando se mueve este fenómeno
conduce a la aparición de una nueva
fuerza la fuerza magnética que es en
realidad una simple fuerza eléctrica
pero percibida desde un punto de vista
diferente
al igual que el campo eléctrico todos
estos comportamientos pueden resumirse
en el campo magnético cuando una carga
eléctrica se mueve crea un campo
magnético a su alrededor que puede
representarse mediante flechas que giran
en torno a la dirección de su movimiento
la fuerza magnética es una consecuencia
de la relatividad especial por lo que el
comportamiento del campo magnético es
bastante sorprendente en un campo
magnético una partícula inmóvil no
siente ninguna fuerza
una partícula en movimiento sentirá una
fuerza que será mayor Cuanto más se
mueva la partícula perpendicularmente a
la dirección del campo magnético esta
fuerza tenderá a hacer que las
partículas giren en hélices y círculos
cuyo tamaño depende de su masa velocidad
intensidad de campo o carga eléctrica
Aunque es difícil de visualizar uno
puede hacerse una idea del campo
magnético imaginando el siguiente
experimento enrollamos un alambre sobre
sí mismo para formar una larga bobina y
le aplicamos una corriente eléctrica a
medida que los electrones se mueven
dentro del cable cada uno de ellos
creará un pequeño campo magnético todos
estos pequeños Campos magnéticos se
suman a un campo a gran escala que forma
una especie de bucle que sale de un
extremo de la bobina y entra por el otro
de este modo nuestra bobina se comporta
como una especie de imán un objeto que
tiene un Polo Norte y un Polo Sur
magnético este tipo de objetos se llama
electroimán como las cargas eléctricas
los polos del mismo tipo se repelen
mientras que los Polos opuestos se
atraen
en el centro de la bobina el campo
magnético es relativamente uniforme
dirigido a lo largo del eje de
enrollamiento del cable
si lanzamos un electrón protón las dos
partículas formarán trayectorias
circulares a causa del campo magnético
pero en direcciones opuestas porque el
electrón es de carga negativa Mientras
que el protón de carga positiva
[Música]
pero por lo general la mayoría de los
imanes no necesitan de una corriente
eléctrica para funcionar algunos imanes
tienen naturalmente un campo magnético
los llamados imanes permanentes las
partículas elementales como el electrón
tienen una propiedad llamada espín
aunque esta no sea la realidad se puede
interpretar al Spin como una rotación de
la partícula sobre sí misma al girar
sobre sí misma la partícula genera una
especie de corriente eléctrica que como
en el caso de la bobina engendrará un
campo magnético las partículas
elementales se comportan así como
diminutos imanes y el agruparlas de
forma alineada podemos crear materiales
magnetizados
[Música]
por último como los campos eléctricos y
magnéticos son inseparables siendo uno
la base del otro es natural unificarlos
en un solo concepto el campo
electromagnético
este campo electromagnético se comporta
De evoluciona de una manera muy
específica que puede resumirse en cuatro
principios fundamentales las cuatro
ecuaciones de Maxwell
la primera ecuación nos dice que una
carga actúa como origen del campo
eléctrico
la segunda ecuación afirma que por el
contrario no puede existir una carga
magnética un objeto que solo tenga un
Polo Norte magnético sin un Polo Sur o
viceversa un Polo Norte magnético
siempre viene acompañado de un Polo Sur
Y si intentamos cortar un imán en dos
inevitablemente acabamos con dos nuevos
imanes más pequeños
Las dos últimas ecuaciones muestran cómo
evolucionan los campos eléctricos y
magnéticos entre sí
la primera de estas dos ecuaciones nos
dice que un cambio en el campo magnético
perturbará al campo eléctrico si movemos
un imán dentro de una bobina de alambre
variamos el campo magnético lo que
perturba el campo eléctrico y pondrá en
movimiento a los electrones
al agitar un imán dentro de una bobina
podemos generar una corriente eléctrica
esto se llama inducción porque una
variación del campo magnético puede
inducir una corriente eléctrica en un
cable Esta técnica se utiliza
ampliamente en las turbinas eólicas las
centrales nucleares y en los teléfonos
para convertir el movimiento en un
corriente
finalmente la cuarta ecuación nos dice
que una corriente eléctrica o una
variación del campo eléctrico provoca
por sí misma una perturbación del campo
magnético Esta última ecuación es
crucial porque nos remite a la ecuación
anterior la variación de un campo
eléctrico perturba el campo magnético
pero esta perturbación del campo
magnético perturbará a su vez el campo
eléctrico esta alternancia entre Campos
eléctricos y magnéticos permite que la
energía electromagnética se propague en
el espacio en forma de una onda
electromagnética que se mueve la
velocidad de los fotones virtuales
incluyen las microondas los rayos x los
infrarrojos y la luz
un gran número de experimentos
interesantes pueden explicarse mediante
las leyes de electromagnetismo como
también se puede frenar la gravedad de
alguna manera para ello basta con dejar
caer un imán sobre una bobina de alambre
inicialmente el imán cae cada vez más
rápido al ser arrastrado por la tierra
pero al acercarse a la bobina su
movimiento hace que cambie el campo
magnético del cable esta variación del
campo magnético pondrá en movimiento los
electrones del interior del cable imán
que cae genera una corriente eléctrica
en la bobina una bobina que transporta
una corriente eléctrica también genera
un campo magnético como un imán este
nuevo campo magnético se opondrá
ligeramente al movimiento del imán que
cae frenando así su caída dentro de la
bobina el imán cae más lentamente
[Música]